nice
commercials
do you want to scream no just just let
him go to the top
yeah huh
let's look at this
mix
all cell phones are off
awesome
two minutes guys
thank you
wow
so
so
um
hello folks
good morning today we received great
news
for our economy and our recovery and for
the american people
this morning we learned that in may our
economy created
559 000 new jobs
unemployment rate fell to 5.8 percent
and wages went up for american workers
that means we have now created over 2
million jobs in total since i took
office
more jobs than ever been created in the
first four months of any presidency in
modern history
triple the ray to my predecessor eight
times the rate of president reagan
the unemployment rate is now below six
percent for the first time since the
pandemic hit
the first 14 months first time first
time in 14 months
we saw the largest decline in the number
of long-term unemployed
more in more than an entire decade in
the last 10 years
long-term unemployment drop by the
second largest amount ever recorded
not only that but the signs of further
progress are already here
this report is based on a weekly uh
uh in a week in early may that's how we
did they determined
the uh the job growth or loss we have
growth
and that was in this that week in may
we only had 35 percent of working age
adults had been fully vaccinated
now we're still all they were still all
wearing masks
since then 21 million more adults have
gotten vaccinated
making it easy for them to return to
work safely in short
this is progress historic progress
progress that's pulling our economy
out of the worst crisis it's been in 100
years
and it's testament to the new strategy
this is growing ours in this economy
not only growing up but going from the
bottom up in the middle out
remember when i took office in january
our economy wasn't a tailspin
job growth had stalled covett was raging
average initial claims for unemployment
insurance were over 830
000 per week now those claims have
fallen below 430 000
about half of what they were when i took
office before i took office
almost 24 million americans were going
hungry
remember those long lines of cars miles
long people waiting for just a box of
food
to be put in their trunk that number has
already dropped by 25
still too many but clear progress
before i took office independent experts
were projecting
that the american economy would grow by
three or four percent
in 2021 this year this week
the organization of economic cooperation
and development the so-called oecd
which makes up a group includes the
world's largest economies and its
membership
and has been one of the leading bodies
analyzing economic growth worldwide in
individual nations
increased their projection for u.s
economic growth this year
to 6.9 percent in 2021 that's the
fastest pace in nearly four decades
in fact the us is the only major economy
where projections of future growth are
stronger today than they were before the
pandemic hit in 2020.
and in may manufacturing activity was
nearly as strong as it was
in more than 15 years stronger than 15
years
no other major economy a major economy
in the world is growing as fast
as ours no other major economy is
gaining jobs as quickly as ours
and none of this success is an accident
it isn't luck it's due in no small part
first of all the cooperation the
american people in responding to my
effort to get covet under control
wearing masks initially and getting
vaccinated
and it's no small part to the bold
action we took by passing the american
rescue plan
the plan provided those resources to get
shots in people's arms
underwrite the vaccination effort enough
vaccine supply for every single american
more vaccinators people to put shots in
the arms and more
vaccination sites and now 52
52 of american adults are fully
vaccinated
75 percent of our seniors are fully
vaccinated
and the american rescue pan plan
delivered economic benefits directly to
the american people
because of that law more than 167
million of those rescue payments of up
to fourteen hundred dollars
have gone out to individual families a
recent study
the census bureau data found just how
much these
checks mattered they drastically reduced
to
reduce depression according to the study
anxiety and hardship for families
more than 40 percent fewer families
struggle to afford food
rent utilities car payments student
loans and health care expenses
small businesses and restaurants are
getting killed
now we're delivering loans and support
they need to reopen and to stay open
schools are struggling to reopen so we
made vaccinating teachers a priority
we delivered schools the much support
they needed
state and local governments had to lay
off tens of thousands of educators and
first responders
many are now back on the job thanks to
the rescue plan
in fact in may state and local
governments added
103 000 education jobs return them to
work
these funds are continuing to get out
this month to support
state and local governments which will
help get more people back to work
small and medium-sized businesses are
now able to take advantage of a special
tax credit called the employee retention
tax credit
it provides businesses a generous tax
credit to retain or
hire more workers through our restaurant
revitalization fund
we anticipate being able to help over
100 000 hard-hit restaurants
stay open or reopen and beginning next
month
most families with children will be
getting a tax cut
which should be going and depositing
their accounts directly into their bank
accounts every month
we know that access to child care is one
of the biggest barriers in the way of
parents going back to work
our administration is delivering 39
billion dollars in child care relief
to help child care providers get back on
their feet the providers
and serve more families and this month
our economy added nearly 20 000
more child care jobs that weren't there
last month
in fact allowing parents to have access
to get help
and temporary boost in unemployment
benefits that ended
that we enacted i should say help people
lost their jobs through no fault of
their own
and who still may be in the process of
getting vaccinated
but it's going to expire in 90 days that
makes sense it expires in 90 days to sum
it up look
covent cases are down cova deaths are up
unemployment filings are down hunger is
down
and vaccinations are up jobs are up
wages are up manufacturing is up
growth is up people gaining health care
coverage is up
and small business confidence is up
america is
finally on the move again as we continue
this recovery
we're going to hit some bumps along the
way of course that'll happen
we can't reboot the world's largest
economy like flipping on a nice
light switch there's going to be ups and
downs in jobs and economic reports
but we're going to be a supply chain
issues and price pressures on the way
back to
stability and steady growth in the
coming weeks
my administration is going to take steps
to combat these supply constraints
building on the work we're doing on the
computer chips
that is we're providing more computer
chips to be manufactured here
in the united states so it doesn't slow
up the manufacturing of automobiles for
example
everyone needs to get their shots though
now's the time to accelerate the process
we've been making now is the time to
build on the foundation we've laid
because all our progress is undeniable
it is not assured
that's why i propose the american jobs
plan
and the americans family plan for
generational investments
we need today we need to make those
investments today
to be able to continue to succeed
tomorrow
we have a chance to seize on the
economic momentum
of the first months of my administration
not just to build back but to build back
better this much is already clear
we're on the right track our plan is
working
and we're not going to let up now we're
going to continue to move on
i'm extremely optimistic i hope you are
as well
and uh may god bless you may god bless
america may god protect our troops thank
you all for being here
on the infrastructure talks i'm going to
be having a talk this afternoon and i'll
be able to report you after that
are you expecting a counteroffer mr
president i'll tell you after i meet
this afternoon